protests are expected tonight at a
community meeting in Phoenix over a
fallout from a video of police officers
confronting a couple and their two small
children the Felix the Phoenix PD has
now released surveillance footage of the
alleged shoplifting that led to the
tense standoff Jeff PJ's is outside
Police Headquarters Jeff who can we
expect to see tonight good morning the
police chief is expected to be there so
is the mayor also the family at the
center of all this is expected they are
- now even though there has been an
apology for the officer's actions the
family does not think that that's enough
and that justice has been served
the officers are still working is just
basically a slap in the face it's like
it's putting some lemon juice on open
wound grave on Ames and Aisha Harper
refused to accept any apologies from the
police chief and mayor following their
controversial ordeal with police what
was it like to be in that situation it's
very terrifying for me and my children
and I always tell my daughters to depend
on the police but she had to find out
herself
the officers were responding to a report
of shoplifting on May 27th surveillance
video newly released by police appears
to back up their claim that Ames stole
underwear and his four-year-old daughter
took a doll from a nearby Dollar Store
yesterday police chief Jerry Williams
called her officer's actions egregious
but denies the family's claim that the
shoplifting was an accident this is more
than about just a doll there were adults
who went to that business in store and
they committed a theft the incident once
again puts a focus on police and
community relations here in Phoenix
back in February we asked a Phoenix
detective and sergeant whether they
think there's a disconnect with the
public I don't think there's a rift
there might be a little misunderstanding
misunderstanding well what's the
difference people forming their own
opinions of police officers you just
based on what they've heard or what
they've seen and so the
fit us all in the same little clump
without really ever had an experience of
their own to judge us Iceland Harris
says it's a problem of the department's
own making Phoenix police shot and
killed his son Jacob who was suspected
of armed robbery in January Harris
doesn't believe the officers version of
events a lot of people are upset because
the loved ones are being killed by these
police and brutalized by the police and
no one's doing anything
the police union released a statement
suggesting that there has been a rush to
judgment in this case it is urging the
public not to jump to conclusions before
an investigation is complete but there
will be more protests planned tomorrow
for a City Council meeting
Anthony Jeff thank you very much